[Music]
for the 23rd annual Miami Book Fair
International the book TV bus is at the
festival this year and inside is Myra
McPherson who's the author of this book
all governments lie the life and times
of rebel journalists is stone when did
you first meet Iestyn in 1977 I covered
one of his anniversary since I mean I
don't I can't remember now but was their
wedding anniversary and I had covered it
I'd read about him but I had not met him
until then and I met him and his wife
and fell madly in love with both of them
he was one of the great troublemakers of
Washington and of course we all knew who
he was even if we hadn't met him
personally who are you writing for I was
writing for the Washington Post and I
did this profile and I still remember
his conversations about his marriage and
when she said that yet the weekly had
become such a success that if it had
gotten in and his wife had been the
chief cook and bottle washer and did
everything with him and he said haven't
gotten any more successful you would
have had to have become a bigamist I
always thought he was wonderful course
he had he had stopped them the weekly in
71 at what point in time did you decide
to write this by office actually 91 I am
it well I should say 90 and was
certainly I knew him well after that
period of time in 88 I was at one of his
last press conference meetings or press
meetings at the Press Club and when he
died in 89 I just thought what a
treasure trove of journalism and it was
important too to write about him and
then as I continued on I ended up
finding the FBI files which were like
5,000 pages on I have stone a man who
never had any secrets never told anybody
anything other than he told his massive
audience at that period because he'd
been writing about the Vietnam War and
but I was just fascinated with what I
found in the FBI files which is just
this constant tracking of a major
civilian person
and spending all our taxpayers money on
doing an awful lot of damage which was
what J Edgar Hoover was famous for so
you really spent 16 years no I stopped
and did another book after my mother
died I did a book on illness loss in
grief and then came back to this book
and it kept haunting me and and I just
felt that I had to finish it what point
in time did I have stone jump from
regular journalist to superstar well
actually he had been he had he had about
three different periods in his life the
first period of his life was in the
early 30s and 40s and he was the
breaking scoop after scoop about Hitler
and about World War two and what was
going on with the cartels and p.m.
magazine which was a major New York
paper and also for the nation and then
he went into the weekly and started that
frankly because he didn't have a job as
he used to joke he said that on every
paper I worked I always thought they
would close on Monday and they always
did and so he had to find his own job
and what happened is he started in 53
which was the period of the McCarthy
witch hunts a terrible time for a lefty
journalist to start anything and he's
just incrementally crept up and crept up
and then he was the first journalist in
America to write about the gulf of
tonkin it was two weeks after LBJ said
that this was excuse for going into
Vietnam people don't remember this
timeframe this was a time when they said
that some shipping some little fishing
boats had had targeted one of our ships
and as he went through the documents as
he was always famous for doing and said
if there's no debris here what really
went on it's very very reminiscent of
what's happened with weapons of mass
destruction and of course he became a
superhero too the anti-war movement and
he became rich and famous and that was
in 1970 and 68 to 70 and then he started
writing a book on Socrates and
and had a best-seller at the age of 80
his life just kept going on it was the
great trajectory of a great American
story of success and his writings were
what made him famous or was it him
speaking and talking in his personality
always a total combination um one of the
great lines he had about weapons of mass
destruction at least I call it web and
semester it was what he wrote back
during the Vietnam period was he was
talking about the fact that one had to
beware of lies and all governments lie
the title comes from his full quote
which was all governments lie but
disaster lies in wait for countries
whose leaders smoke the same hashish
they give out and he was writing of
course about the Vietnam period but he
was very witty and very funny and he
always had these pithy one-liners but
his whole being and persona was based on
a scholarship
scholarly look at what went on
historically so he had a point of
reference for everything and on top of
that he was quite able to transcend past
things and make it applicable for today
and a great reader reader I mean John
Stewart would have loved to have him as
a as a guest writer because he was so
witty and provocative but he also did
enormous research his whole concept was
read the documents don't listen to what
the people are telling you at the top go
into the into the bowels of government
find your own people do not get cozy
with the top officials and as we have
seen today that's a classic example of
how to be a good journalist it sounds
like journalism 101 yes absolutely what
impact did he have at that time he had
an enormous impact he I think the book
is full of interviews with people who
were influenced by him large small some
names some not sy Hersh is one of them
many of today's journalists Carl
Bernstein
they they treasured what is he did and
he also had a an impact far beyond just
his 70,000 readership which is in itself
quite quite phenomenal for a little
four-page weekly but what he did with
that was had so much information and it
started filtering into every other area
in fact about one of the leaders of the
LA the LA Times and The New York Times
said that we started having easy around
talk to because he knew more than that a
lot of us did and it was because he was
always out there relentlessly pursuing
everything so he became a role model for
a very good collection of younger
journalists
besides the FBI files what other files
and papers did you have access to to
work to write well I went into all of
the later files that came out of the
Cold War period including North Korea
China and and Russia and pulled up all
the files about what Izzy was writing at
the time to do a comparison point I also
compared him with walter Lippmann who
was one of the the people who was
considered the great establishment sage
and found out that Izzy was far more
prescient and on the mark then then
walter Lippmann was about so many areas
of Washington and national news from the
20s on through the 70s so he's a true
hero to a lot of people what was his
relationship with presidents he didn't
have he was not one of these people who
said the presidents I have known he felt
distancing was more important when the
interesting is about Izzy too is that he
was going deaf at the age of 30 and so
he learned to read because he wasn't
sure that he could trust what he was
hearing adequately in those days and of
course that was pre tape recorders etc
and so he started doing a lot of
documentary reading and that was where
he became so honored and revered by
people he didn't have friends in the
White House he was not that kind of guy
was he considered an opinion journalist
at the
yes and no he did all kinds of things he
was a straight journalist just straight
as he said bird dog reporting and he
broke stories he broke the stories about
American cartels still doing business
with Nazi Germany in 1940 41 before them
we entered the war he was also an
opinion essayist but he always labeled
it opinion an essay you always knew what
where he was going with that and he
became known as a real scholar I mean
this was a man who as I said graduated
third in his class but that's third from
the last in high school and he never
finished college and he became a great
autodidact he taught himself everything
from the early Greek era straight on
through and he used everything he could
possibly use to study what he was doing
somebody said he would have been a great
lawyer he also asked those tough lawyer
like questions he used to say to
journalists don't ask a question unless
you know what their answer is going to
be and be sure that you can track it
with whether that's a correct answer or
just something that they're giving you I
know his critics at the time who were
they and how powerful were they well J
Edgar Hoover was was the major critic
and they chased him they they went
through his garbage they chased him into
the cigar store they chased every
conversation ever had all you could hear
him saying often was what and this was
all illegal if it was not illegal it was
often unethical and McCarthy if he
battled McCarthyism during the 50s when
most Americans were cowed we have to you
have to look at the book to realize just
how badly the the media had been
affected by that period and and people
were being fired for just simply whether
or not they had known a friend who was a
communist thirty years earlier so he was
a true pariah in that period of time
what's been the reaction that you've
gotten on your book tour
amazing what's one wonderful is that
every review says it's so timely so it
took me a long time it's sort of hitting
people right now with with the concept
of what's been going on for the last
five years both in American journalism
and and and in the government that's
been playing out how long did it take
you to actually write this book it's a
pretty big tome no there's an awful lot
of Izzi in it and a lot of quotes from
him because he's such a wonderful writer
that I want him to be be a part of it I
I think on and off I would say it took
me about ten years ten years I've
written three other books before none
none took as long this is the book it's
called all governments lie it's a
biography of I have stone the author is
my rep McPherson and she's joining us at
the Miami Book Fair thank you thank you